>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> Let me introduce tonight's
presenter, presenters,
and then I'll mute myself so they can talk.
So we have Christy Feinfield, a reference
librarian in the Library of Congress Prints
and Photographs Division, specializing in visual
materials relating to the concept of place.
Christy has a bachelor's of architecture
from Virginia Tech, and an [inaudible]
from the Catholic University of America.
She writes for the Library's Picture This blog
and also helps moderate the
Library's Flickr account.
Her recent video series with historian
Sam Waters, "Every Photo is a Story",
discusses strategies for
researching photographs.
Joining Christy is Tom Bober.
Tom serves as the Library of
Congress 2015 and '16 teacher
in residence for audio/visual materials.
A librarian at R. M. Campton Elementary School
in Clayton, Missouri, Tom has used a variety
of primary sources on historical and
scientific topics from the Library of Congress
to help students construct knowledge.
Tom and Christy, take it away.
>> Thank you, Cheryl.
As you've just heard, my name is Christy
Feinfield, and I'm a reference librarian
in the Prints and Photographs Division,
or P and P, at the Library of Congress.
Being a reference librarian in
P and P means my job focuses
on connecting researchers and visual materials.
I do that work in person in the Prints and
Photographs Reading Room, over the phone,
and through our Ask A Librarian e-mail service.
And today Tom and I will be connecting you
with visual materials with a focus on how
to explore photos and the
stories around them as well
as make them a part of your
classroom experience.
The Prints and Photographs Division
holds the national picture collection
of the United States.
While international in scope, the
collections are particularly rich
in materials either produced in the US or
documenting the history of lives, interests,
and achievements of the American people.
The 15.6 million collection, images
in the collection include photographs,
by far the most common format, fine
and popular prints and drawings,
posters and architectural
and engineering drawings.
Every year on average, the
collections grow by about 300,000 items,
and we digitize about 50,000 images
to add to our online catalog.
More than 1.2 million images are available
online through the Library of Congress website,
and we'll start by talking about
how you can find those images.
Be aware that guidance and help with our
questions is available on site at the Library
of Congress in the Prints and
Photographs Reading Room and from offsite
through the Ask a Librarian service.
On the Library of Congress website,
there are many places to find visuals.
We will include a few slides at the end of
our presentation today to help you find all
of the online sources for images
through the Library of Congress.
While the bulk of the images at the Library are
found in the Prints and Photographs Division,
with the Library of Congress search
system, you can find visual materials
from throughout the Library's
divisions on our website.
There are search tips specific to each catalog
and search system available through the Library
of Congress, but today I'm going
to offer a few quick tips on how
to achieve better results
when looking for images.
The first primary tip is think visually.
Use words to describe what
you hope to see in an image.
For example, instead of trying World
War II home front as your search,
try victory garden, women
factory, scrap aluminum.
Use fewer words.
Many records in our catalogs are
transcriptions of a caption or caption card.
So, for instance, an individual's first name
may not be included or fully spelled out.
Be sure to check the spelling
and spacing of your search words.
Are there alternate spellings?
Could two words have been combined into
one or vice versa in image caption?
For example, street car versus streetcar.
Have you used abbreviations
that can be spelled out?
This is especially important
when searching for addresses.
Avenue versus at A-V-E or street for S-T.
Read descriptions of individual collections
to zero in on those relevant collections,
and browse the items within collections
to see how images are described
and for ideas of search terms to try.
While all types of visuals
can be useful in teaching,
today I'm going to talk primarily
about photographs.
Recently, I worked with architectural
and landscape historian Sam Waters
to create a five-part video series
entitled "Every Photo is a Story".
In this series, one of our goals was to both
share the stories captured in photos as well
as offer tips and tools for viewers
to use when studying photographs
and learning directly from those images.
The collection featured in the video series
contains 1,100 largely hand colored lantern
slides of gardens created by
photographer Francis Benjamin Johnston.
The photos were created between
the 1910's and the 1930's.
To accompany the videos, I also created try it
yourself exercises which allow you to apply some
of the tips suggested in the videos
to other photographs and collections
in the Prints and Photographs Division.
I hope you'll explore the videos and the
exercises for more hands-on practice.
Today I will walk us through the five sections
of the video and how they can offer a structure
to guide you in getting more from a
photo than just a good illustration.
Part One, start to read a photograph,
suggests questions to the viewer
and potential researcher, starting
from perhaps the most patently obvious
and then digging a little deeper.
The top tip suggests looking closely
at the image, front and back.
We suggests you ask questions and
make no assumptions about an image
or its description, title, or caption.
Describe what you see, look for related photos
to put the image in context, and, finally,
ask how the photographer is shaping the scene.
In this part, we introduced viewers to the idea
that photographs are not necessarily
a mechanical recording of fact
and should be studied with that in mind.
In the time provided, we'll only be able
to touch on a few of the tips suggested
in each part, but I hope to give
a hint at what can be learned
about a photograph with some exploration.
Let's start with a brief exercise based on the
tips for Part One, start to read a photograph.
Feel free to click on the link below the
image to view a larger version of the photo.
I've selected a photograph from the Prints
and Photographs Division's collection.
This photo is also featured in one of the
Try it Yourself exercises available on the
"Every Photo is a Story" website.
Take a moment to look closely
at this photograph.
Do you see details that might offer
clues to what is going on here?
What stands out to you as unusual?
What observations can you make about the people?
I'll let you look for a moment
before we continue.
[ Pause ]
OK. I'm going to now give some examples
of what can be gathered by close looking
at the high resolution file
of these, of this image.
I always look for anything
with text on it in an image.
A street sign, an address, name of a business,
etc. Finding text within a photograph is
a great way to find out concrete details.
Let's look together at some of
the details I was able to observe
by zooming in on the digital image.
Here we have the text of an oath
of allegiance to the United States.
It is also a renouncement of loyalty
to a previous foreign country.
Looking closely at the people in the
classroom, at least two observations stand out.
All of the people here have the appearance
of being students by virtue of being seated
at desks with books in front of them, but many
look older than the average college student.
Also, the people seated would appear to be
of different ethnicities based
on facial characteristics.
Combined with the oath, this starts to
suggest a reason they are in the room.
Let's keep looking.
More text can be found on the other chalkboard.
This one has the English alphabet as
well as an assignment to write sentences.
Taken on its own, this would
seem more appropriate
to students in a grade school classroom.
So is this, in fact, a classroom?
The two women standing in the
classroom, including this one in front
of the assignment, could be teachers.
They don't appear to have
recently vacated a student desk.
A really close look at the book in one of the
men's hands reveals an image of the Statue
of Liberty, a very strong symbol of America
and one often associated with immigrants.
At this point, I try to speculate
what the photo is showing.
Who are these people?
Why are they in a classroom?
Asking questions is the best
way to elicit answers.
It's also a good way to check your assumptions
and see if you have evidence to back them.
I can assume this a classroom at
first glance, but it's important
to then find reasons to support that assumption.
With your observations and speculations in hand,
let's turn to the accompanying
information in the online catalog.
The catalog records, which accompany images from
the Prints and Photographs Division vary widely
in the amount of detail and
type of information provided.
This is often a function of what level
of cataloging was completed as well
as what the source for the descriptions was.
A caption card file, the information
found on the object itself,
a title divides by a visual materials cataloger.
Different items in collections come
with different amounts of information.
So you have to work with what is provided.
In this case, we are provided a very
simple title of Americanization class.
If you go to the notes area of the catalog
description, you will see that the title comes
from quote unverified data provided
by the National Photo Company
on the negative or negative sleeve.
This tells you a few things.
The information, including the title,
have not been checked by a staff person,
and that the words used came directly
from the time the photograph was taken
and from the source of the photo.
What does the word Americanization mean here?
This is when it's helpful to compare your
observations and conclusions gathered
by looking closely with what is
provided in written form with the photo.
How well did they match up?
What were the differences?
When you know the data is
unverified, it can pay to be skeptical,
and see if you can find visual
evidence to support
or dispute the provided title or caption.
Another tip we offer in Part One of the
webcast is to search for related photos
in the same collection as well as
outside that specific collection.
I can start the search by typing the
title I was given into a search blank.
A search for Americanization class in the
same collection offers a close variant
to the photo we started with.
Studying this image offers additional
insight and likely stimulates more questions.
Explore other photos in the collection.
What kind of photos are they?
What kinds of topics do they cover?
Searching elsewhere in the collection could also
offer different perspectives on the photograph,
and place it within a new context.
I'm going to turn it over
to Tom for a few slides now.
>> As you're preparing to use images
with students, you'll want to think
about how students will access the image files.
They may be looking at the image on a
projector screen or interactive whiteboard.
They may be looking at the image on
their own device or on a desktop,
laptop, or tablet in a small group.
They may be looking at a printout of the image.
A lot of this will have to do with
the technology that's available to you
and your students, and some of
this may be based on the level
and detail you want your students to see.
Printing the image will not allow, usually
allow you to see some of the details
that Christy just pointed out in the photo
we were looking at, and in that case,
you'll want to view the file digitally,
and you'll want to download the
highest resolution tif file if you can.
Just like any large file, if you have the
opportunity, download these files ahead of time.
It can save you from any Internet
hiccups or long download times
that you can experience in your school.
If the image doesn't contain fine details,
the largest jpeg file could be
acceptable for viewing on a screen.
When printing, I usually do a test print to make
sure that I'm able to see the level of detail
and sharpness that will allow my
students to analyze the image.
Speaking of analyzing, the Library
of Congress has a teachers' page
at loc dot gov slash teachers that has a
primary source analysis tool for students
and teacher question prompts
to help with image analysis.
Here, I'm on the Library
of Congress teachers' page.
On the left, I clicked on using primary sources,
then I clicked on teachers'
guide and analysis tool.
The primary source analysis tool can
be filled out and printed online,
or there's a link to a pdf version.
I'll show that you in a, an
example of that in just a moment.
The teachers' guide is a pdf.
Here's the teachers' guide.
You'll notice that it's organized in four
categories - observe, reflect, question,
and at the bottom, further investigation.
These are the steps that we want students
to go through when analyzing an image.
Observations are going to be specific
things that can be seen in the photo.
So you may ask what did you notice
first, or what is the physical setting?
Making observations are what we've done
in the first step of Christy's analysis
of this photo, of the photo from earlier.
Reflections ask students to infer
based on their observations as well
as their own understanding of the world.
So I might ask what's happening in the image.
They will bring in their observations of the
photo and what they know about classrooms
to make it reflections in their
analysis, and questions are just that
but can sometimes be difficult, a
difficult part of analysis for students.
What does this photo make you wonder about?
What is still a mystery to you?
What do you want to know more about?
Those questions that students ask can
help guide next steps in their thinking.
At the bottom are suggestions for
how students can show their learning
from their photo analysis.
This is mockup of the primary source
analysis tool that students may use.
You'll notice it has the same
categories as the teachers' guide.
I want to point out a few things that I
encourage when my students are analyzing.
First, I don't ask them to
write in complete sentences.
Some do naturally.
Others like to list things,
especially when making observations.
Second, you might notice the arrows
drawn between the categories.
I sometimes ask my students to do this
to help them explain their thinking.
Students' reflections and questions
should naturally connect to one
or more things they saw in the image.
So, for example, if a student in the reflection
writes that they think this is a classroom,
but in their observations has nothing
written that relates to a classroom,
they haven't really made their thinking visible.
That, of course, doesn't mean that
they aren't thinking about it,
but making those thoughts visible through the
primary source analysis tool can help them
when they're sharing their ideas or taking that
analysis into a larger aspect of their learning.
Also, and you can't see it through this example,
but a student analyzing an image using
this tool is not a linear process.
They don't fill out all of
their observations and then all
of their reflections and
then all of their questions.
I'm expecting them to jump around.
Many of them start with an observation or two.
It's a natural starting point, but then they'll
move between the three columns from there.
And, finally, my recommendation, if you have
students who have never read an image before is
to model this with them as a whole
group, much like Christy did,
started to do with the previous image.
No matter how old they are, have them
do another in pairs or small groups.
You'll be surprised how that collaboration can
help students see things or think about things
that they would not on their own.
With that base knowledge of the
tools, students and teachers have
at their disposal let's dive deeper into
the analysis of our image with Christy.
>> Thank you, Tom.
Those were all great points, and those tools
must come in extremely handy in a classroom.
Let's move on to Part Two.
In Part Two, get to know the photographer,
we look to the person behind the camera
and ask viewers to apply basic research skills,
much as one might with any research topic.
The researcher should consult secondary
reference sources, both printed and online,
track down primary sources such
as magazine and newspaper articles
from the photographer's lifetime, and if you're
lucky, locate the papers and the photographer.
Use these sources to establish a chronology of
key dates and places in the photographer's life.
As with title and caption
information, the information available
about the photographer can vary
widely, and understanding that is key
to working with archival collections.
In some cases, we not only know the
photographer but know a great deal
about the photographer's
life, influences, and career.
In other cases, we know the
photographer's name but little about them.
And as in this case, we sometimes do not
know the name of the photographer at all.
As you can see, there's no creator
listed in our catalog record.
When we do not know the photographer, and even
when we do, it's good to turn to the collection
which the photo is part of to learn more.
That information is provided
in the record itself as well
as at the top right in the part of box.
Clicking the link there takes you
to the home page of the collection.
On this home page for the collection, there will
away be an about this collection entry as well
as sometimes articles and
essays about the collection.
In many cases, these include biographical
information, the scope of the collection,
explanations of how the collection was
acquired, cataloged, digitized, and organized.
Learning this information places the
single photograph into a telling context.
In Part Three, consider how the photos
were made, we shift our attention
from the photographer to the object.
In the case of the video series, the
photo and the colored lantern slide.
Consider the original photograph.
What size is it?
What format?
What camera was used to create it?
How does this influence your
understanding of the image?
Take into consider what happens
after the shutter snaps.
What changes or manipulations
may have been made?
Consider the photographer's time
involved in making the image.
Consider the client, the purpose of the
photo, the audience for which it was intended.
Today we're going to focus on
how thinking about the audience
for a photograph affects how
we view and understand it.
Let's return to the information about
the National Photo Company collection.
This photo of an Americanization class
was taken by a photographer working
for the National Photo Company, but who
was the target audience for the photo?
Why was this photo taken?
There are a few places this information can
be gleaned for the collection as a whole.
One is the about this collection and the
supporting documents I mentioned in Part Two.
The other is what is known as a guide record.
These can be found in the Library of
Congress online catalog for collections
from the Prints and Photographs Division.
They are compact summaries
of creator, date, subject,
and historical information
for an entire collection.
You can see part of what such a record
looks like at the right of the slide.
By reading over the about this collection and
the guide record for the National Photo Company,
I find information about different
audiences for the photographs.
According to these two documents, photographers
for the NPCC undertook photographic assignments
for local businesses and government agencies,
and they also took photos to sell to newspapers,
news distributors, and other photo agencies.
We don't know at this time why this
photograph was taken or for what purpose.
How do you think the audience for the
photo would affect how it was framed?
What would be included or left out?
The photographer has control over when
and how he or she takes the photo.
For example, a photographer working for a
news agency might be thinking about the market
for this photo while the photographer working
for a government agency sponsoring
this class might want
to show the class in the best possible light.
Can you guess the audience just
by looking at the photograph?
What evidence supports your speculation?
[ Background Sounds ]
Part Four takes a broader view by
suggesting we explore the photographer's era.
Like any art form, photographs
are not created in a vacuum.
We discuss the time period
during which the work was made.
In the case of the videos, Johnston's
work was taking place during the heart
of the progressive era and
the city beautiful movement,
and that certainly influenced her
choices and the work she received.
Aesthetic preferences, art movements, landscape
design, composition, all of these had an impact
on the work Johnston did as
well as how it was received.
One way to learn about the photographer's era
is to turn to published sources like newspapers
and magazines of the time period.
"Chronically in America" on the Library
of Congress website offers free access
to digitized newspapers dating
from 1836 to 1922.
To try and answer my own question about
audience for the photograph as well
as what the term Americanization meant at the
time of the photo, I tried a simple search
for the phrase Americanization
class and was lucky enough
to get the page on the right as my first result.
At lower right, I find the exact
photograph we've been talking about.
Let's look a little closer.
As you can see at lower right, this search
gave me several new pieces of information.
A more complete caption,
where the photo was taken,
what nationalities the students represent,
confirmation that the women standing
are the teachers, and their names.
We also now have more information about the
date as this photo was featured in the August 8,
1920, edition of the "Sunday Star".
I also know that at least one audience for this
photograph was this newspaper in Washington,
D.C. By reading the rest of the page to see
what other photos were featured in this section
as well as pursuing the other results from
my search in "Chronically in America",
I can also start to glean more information about
this photo and the time period it belongs to.
I can find more hints about the
term Americanization as well.
The fifth and final part is where
we pull the threads together
to interpret the stories we discovered.
In the top tips for this section, we
reinforce the themes of each part.
We encouraged viewers to look closely at the
photographs to study who took the picture,
to search for related written information, and
to ask lots of questions and to ask for help.
As always, we encourage you to seek
out reference librarians like myself,
archivists, historians, and other experts.
So keeping all that in mind, what
is the story of this photograph?
We know a bit more about the
circumstances of the photo now.
We have the who, what, when,
where, and how of the image.
This is a good point to think about the photo
itself, and then to step outside the photo
and ask how this photo fits into
the bigger story of America in 1920.
And I'm going to turn things over
to Tom, and he'll tell you how
to bring these strategies to the classroom.
>> Thanks, Christy.
The final step that Christy asked
us to do here, and if I can,
I'm going to go back to these questions.
They are really the further investigations
that we would ask students to do.
What's the story of this photograph?
How does this story fit into the
story of America in the 1920's?
How does a student then share
what he or she knows?
How do they fit it into the larger context
of a time period or an event or a biography?
This is truly where analysis and images
fits into student thinking and learning.
A final few things to think about when
including images into student learning.
How do you want students to access the image?
Are they given to the students by the teacher?
Are the students going to be searching for
images on their own, and what kind of time is
that going to take and skill on their part?
Regarding bibliographic information.
Do you want students to have it all at once?
When should they have it?
Sometimes like in our example today, you
want them just thinking about the photo
and asking questions before they have any of
the bibliographic information that gives some
of those answers, but may lead
to other questions and searches
like we saw with our image today.
Don't forget about the creator's voice.
It's very easy to focus so much on
what the camera caught that we forget
that the person behind it was taking that photo
for a reason, and that reason reveals some
of the story that he or she is trying to tell.
Be thinking before your students even ask for
it about other sources that can be brought
in to complement the image, both
primary sources and secondary sources,
and this happens for one of two reasons.
Either the other resource is
informing the students about the photo,
or the photo is informing the
students about the other resource.
So thinking about how all of those resources
fit together and playing with those ideas
as a teacher can really lead to deep
layered learning on students' parts.
And, finally, from personal experience,
this may look messy the first time.
Students may not get to where you
want them to be in their thinking.
While extremely beneficial, it's not always
intuitive for students to learn in this way,
and it wasn't intuitive for
me to teach in this way.
I had to try it, reflect on the steps,
what I said, the results, make changes
and try it again, and I know
that sounds like a lot of work,
and if the amazing student thinking
didn't happen the more I did this,
I wouldn't be talking to you about it today.
I want to share a few additional
resources with our last three slides,
and I'm not going to go deeply into all of
these, but just point a few things out quickly.
These are all additional related resources for
you to explore, and Christy and my idea was
to give you things that you could go
back to later and look at more closely.
They're all linked, and they'll be available
in the archive of this presentation.
I'll mention on this page in particular
the Ask a Prints and Photograph librarian.
It is an incredible resource.
When you feel like you are getting stuck,
and you don't know where else to go,
this is a great place where you
can go and ask your question
of an actual individual, and
they'll get back with you.
It's wonderful, and I've used it,
and had great results from it.
Here are several links that start to
make the million plus images available
through the Library of Congress
much more manageable.
I won't point everything out to you, but I will
point out the interesting things, I'm sorry,
it won't point everything out to you, but
it will point to interesting things that you
or a colleague may be able
to use in your classroom.
I'm a big fan of the Picture This blog.
I subscribe to it.
So I just receive e-mails anytime there are
new posts, and even if it isn't an image
that I may be interested in right away, often
I tuck it back, and I found myself going back
to that blog time and time again to pull
something for myself or a colleague.
And these are teacher resources
from the Library of Congress.
The teacher page that I mentioned earlier is
here as well as the blog which not only points
to resources but to teaching
strategies for using those resources.
I think it's amazing.
And at this point, I'm going to hand it
over to Cheryl for some final information.
>> Thanks, Tom.
Thanks, Christy, and thanks to all the
participants for the lively discussion,
and we have quite a few questions
waiting for you.
So the first question I think
is probably for Tom, although,
Christy, you might have ideas, too.
Let's let Tom start.
The question is can some tips for using
photograph analysis with younger students.
>> Absolutely.
So I am in an elementary school before I was
here with the Library for this school year,
and we did quite a bit of
analysis as early as kindergarten.
So five years, six years old.
And I would say the first thing is that if
you can, actually having that print copy
of the image is really beneficial.
They are tactile.
They want to touch it.
They want to point to it, and they
want to kind of get their hands on it.
If they can have a pencil or a crayon and
circle, mark on the image, that is wonderful.
Now if you work with the little ones, you
know they're going to be talking anyway.
So you might as well make it
as collaborative as possible.
Give them a couple of minutes
to talk to a partner.
Then bring it back and talk
with the whole group.
You're going to really start to tease out ideas
and get this wonderful collective thinking going
on when you have all of that, all
of those ideas thrown out together.
And have an idea of what you think, where you
think, excuse me, students are going to go,
but also be open for different ideas.
I know that when we work with older
students or when we do this with adults,
we have a really strong idea of where
they're going to go because we are adults.
So we're closer in age, but I've always find
myself surprised what students find important,
and on that note, sometimes I also really
target those observations with questions
like what do you think is important in this
image, or what do you think is interesting
in this image, and I might need to ask
them follow-up questions to really start
to understand their thinking because they
may not be able to initially verbalize it.
So those are a few ideas for working
with images with younger students.
>> Tom, a follow-up question to that
is what has surprised you in working
with students on, using pictures.
>> I'd say simply that I try to think through
every direction that they are going to go
with their observations, their reflections,
and their questions, and, inevitably,
even when I've done a, an analysis with
a group of five, six, seven year olds,
and since I'm in the Library, I'll do it with
three classes, I can come back the next year,
and I can have a student bring back up something
that not only did I not think of but those 60,
70, 80 kids the year before didn't think of.
And so it's just being open to all those
directions, and I find myself having
to really step back and make sure that I'm
not guiding that image analysis too much.
That I'm listening to what they're saying
and then asking them clarifying questions
to let them lead the analysis so
I don't shut down that thinking.
>> Could you talk a little bit about
the kinds of the items that excite you
as teacher/librarian or that your students
have responded particularly well to?
>> I think the key thing that
I like to do is two things.
First of all, bring in images
that have other children in them.
My students seem to react really well to those.
They feel like they're in a place
where they can speak to that.
It could be images at school,
at home, on the street.
It doesn't seem to matter.
They react to images of children.
And then the other thing, and this has
to do with when you bring the image
in to do the analysis, bringing it in
before, I've had less success bringing
that in before students are, have any
exposure with their classroom teacher.
More often, once they have a little bit of
background with their classroom teacher,
maybe not too much, but that's a great time to
bring in a photo to start to look at that idea
in a different way or in a deeper way because
they'll have a little bit of a grounding,
and they'll feel like they can really
contribute something to that analysis.
>> So, Tom, go ahead, and there's
another follow-up question for you.
Do you ever use props related
to what's in the photograph
to make the experience more multi-sensory?
>> I'm trying to think of an
example where I have done that,
and to be completely honest with you, I haven't.
I think probably the closest we've done is
we've had some images of school settings
that we've analyzed, and we have walked
around the school to clarify some things.
Sometimes a group will, and this
is where things get interesting
when students have disagreements.
So how do you resolve that
dis, those disagreements,
and the place where you can resolve
disagreements are in the observations.
You should be able to agree on the observations.
You may not agree on the reflections,
but you can agree on the observations.
So when students are trying
to bring in their own context,
and we can get quick access to that context.
So we can get quick access to those school
settings, then take advantage of that,
and so I think in that sense, those
props, those, that may be related
to the photograph would be a great
way to [inaudible] that context
and give them another way that they can bring
in their own knowledge to
then reflect on the photo.
>> One point I was going to make is that
the same photo can offer different levels
of information for different audiences.
So even though our "Every Photo is a Story"
series is kind of geared towards older students
or adults, it's possible to take the same photo
and change the kind of questions
you're asking to.
If you take, for an example, we have
photographs of Civil War soldiers.
So if you show some, a young student a
photograph of an African American soldier,
it will definitely give them
questions about what was the role
of African Americans in the Civil War.
They may or may not know that.
They can look at the person
and observe how old they are.
You know, does that person look older than you?
Things like that, and then
you can take that same photo
to a different level with
different interest groups.
So some people are studying the uniforms.
Some people are determining
what states they fought for.
What state, what kind of soldier they are.
So it's just a point to make that,
just because you see a photograph used
for a certain age group, it's possible
that you can look at it a different,
from a different angle and offer
it to a younger audience as well.
>> Excellent points, Christy, and you've
generated some additional conversation.
We have time for just a couple more
questions, but before we take those,
let me just point out some ending
housekeeping in case people need to duck out.
That we would appreciate your
feedback on this session.
We have a three-question survey.
So it'd be great if you could
click through that.
It's on the slide, and I also
pasted it into the chat box.
For completing this session, you can earn a
certificate, you have earned a certificate
for one instructional hour, and you'll
receive an e-mail within five business days
with instructions on how to access that.
So a question for Christy.
Christy, what are the most interesting
kinds of questions that you fielded,
or if you have a single one that stands out?
A little insight into your life as a
reference librarian, and what gets you excited?
>> I, you know, one of the
things that's exciting for me is
that I get a different kind
of question every day.
There's certainly recurring questions.
We have people, since we're in DC, people often
come in and ask for help finding historic photos
of the place they live, or an area
they know in DC, and that's always fun
because it is definitely a treasure hunt through
our collections to find that exact location
at the time period they're interested in.
But something I find interesting as when a user
comes to me and wants to use visual materials
in a way I hadn't thought of before.
I had a researcher come in who was actually
looking at some of our 18th century drawings
for a modern purpose, and,
typically, folks who are looking
at those older drawings,
it's are an academic reason.
And this gentleman was actually part of
an archeological dig, and they were trying
to find artifacts from the French and
Indian War, if I remember correctly,
and he was able to use drawings done in 1760
to actually pinpoint an area that he was going
to go back and look into and try to find a
structure of a fort from that time period.
So it was a use for that particular
drawing I had not occurred to me before.
And I try to, you know, a lot of the
questions that come to mind I feature
in our Picture This blog, which is a fun
way for me to explore them or share the kind
of discoveries I make day by day.
I wanted to go back to quickly to an earlier
mention of students who love mysteries,
and one thing I would point out that if you
go back to the Picture This blog as well
as the Flickr account for
the Library of Congress,
you'll see that recently we've actually been
posting what we call our mystery photos.
We have collections for which there are no
captions on the photos, and we are selecting
out groups of them, ones that we think are
solvable mysteries, and we're posting them
on our Flickr account and asking
people to try to figure it out.
So we don't actually know
the answer in many cases.
So it is a true challenge for people, and
we do get a really good response for that,
and I think it would be an interesting
lesson for perhaps older students,
some of them are tricky, but
there's certainly clues there
that would appeal to many age groups.
So that's something that we try to do and
engage people with our photos in different ways.
>> Thanks, Christy, and there were a number
of comments earlier in your presentation
in the chat about the value of engaging
students in mysteries, and what's more exciting
than a real mystery that
even the experts don't know.
Students so infrequently get a chance
to explore that, to experience that.
I'm going to wrap this up.
I think we've answered all
the questions that came in.
Again, thanks to Tom and Christy
for a rich and lively conversation,
and thanks to everybody who participated.
This works because you come and make it work.
So, again, it would help us if you
would take this very short survey.
The link is on the slide,
and, ah, thank you, Dana.
Dana Bell has posted in the exact link
to the blog post that I was reaching for.
So thanks for that.
This will be, I'll be closing
this off in about thirty seconds.
So grab that survey link, and thanks so much.
I'm going to stop the recording now.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.